everyone's self-scouting themselves
joe judge picking up on the trend that
chris
it's every time i hear it now i think of
you and more and more people are saying
it maybe it happened all the time and i
just never noticed it until i started
hanging around you no no but i think i
started lightly i think i started
slightly redundant but we love it no we
have to self-scout ourselves at all
times and that's what joe judge is
trying to do trying unsuccessfully so
far yeah well i mean you know he's in a
tough spot i mean of course his team's
not very good we know that they're
they're somewhat of a rebuild type mode
right now and they're playing the 49ers
or
yeah a team that was banged up but still
is more talented and better than they
are with a you know incredibly good
coaching staff to go along with it and i
don't know mike i mean i know you we
were paying attention that on sunday but
it's 16 to 6.
it looked like the momentum was all on
the 49er side at that point and i have
no like no issue with him going for it
there i don't down 10 points against
that football team right there and
momentum had totally seemed to be back
on the 49ers side
um yeah that wasn't like crazy you know
that that's one of those two where i
just get annoyed with fans and like the
media because if he punts it away
everyone's gonna go
whoa why did he put it away i mean
they're up by 10 and you're seeing the
49ers are driving the ball down the
field it will you gotta you got to match
it and be aggressive and it's just where
it was like football fans sometimes we
can't have it both ways the game's not
perfect
and uh i got yeah i i remember i
remember last year when pat shurmur was
the coach he would punt in that
situation to help keep the final score
from being an embarrassment right look
good in the newspaper right instead of
being aggressive and trying to salvage
the game let's just get out of here with
a score that isn't going to be a
humiliation exactly shows up tomorrow
morning right a casual fan that wasn't
paying attention joe judd's trying to
turn
a a defeat into an opportunity to at
least make the game close
although i feel bad
for giants fans and jets fans they that
the teams are both horrendous this year
i think it's the first time they're
they're also 0-3 at the same time since
1996 uh so not a good time to be a new
york sports fan although i guess if
you're because you're you're one of the
others so if you're a giants fan you're
happy the jets suck if you're a jets fan
you're happy the giants suck and the
49ers 2-0 at metlife stadium as josh
alper of pft pointed out over the
weekend and maybe the only team to win
two games at metlife stadium this year
and they won in a unique statistical way
chris check this out no puns
no turnovers
and 2.7 yards per rush it's only
happened twice before the teams had no
punts no turner turnovers and three
yards or less per rushing attempt but it
was just methodical it was grinding and
that's what this 49ers offense is yeah
it is you're you're exactly right and it
showed its versatility too like oh okay
yeah we can't beat you up on first and
second down with the great shanahan run
scheme and all that the giants got a lot
of big people on their defensive line so
i wasn't shocked that they slowed it
down a little bit but i think the like
the thing that the 49ers are going to be
impressed by and like where it is it's a
statistical oddity to me not running for
that many yards and still put up that
many points and not punt the ball they
killed it on third down that's what they
did i mean shanahan was amazing in this
football game the giants went in with
the right approach like let's make nick
mullins have to win the football game
let's not let them you know run the ball
down our throats and he doesn't have to
do anything so they did a good job
slowing that aspect down but shanahan
had a lot of ways to expose the giants
in the secondary he did a great job
there you know had his all usual
reverses and screens and things like
that too to keep them off balance and
nick mullins well he he played really
good football so it wasn't pretty early
but they kind of found their mojo and
then once they found their mojo it was
pedal to the metal on the defense and
offensive side of the ball and that was
that
let's hear from kyle shanahan who can
seize that remember the snoopy trophy
that they gave to the jets john's game
he's taking that snoopy trophy home he
beat both teams here he is talking about
his offense from sunday
he was very efficient um and made all
the plays that were there and then made
a number of plays that weren't there i
extended a few had a few big third downs
a few big second alongs
he
kept us on the field for a while and
played tough and i was very impressed
with them and each time i watched it i
feel stronger about that
that's obviously shanahan referring to
quarterback nick mullins who took the
place of jimmy garoppolo proving that he
can run the offense he can run the
system it puts a little heat on jimmy g
number one to get his butt back on the
field right number two to play better
when he comes back because again i think
this is a critical year for jimmy g and
we saw not a great performance week one
against arizona their schedules softened
early there's going to be some tests
coming up when he's healthy when he's
back he's going to have to play well
against some of these nfc west teams or
how can you not consider your options
they considered one of their options
this past year with tom brady maybe they
consider their options going forward
well i think this does like put a little
pressure on jimmy garoppolo you know not
that he's like oh no my job's in
jeopardy but you know you just you see
like the 49ers it's more than just the
quarterback the team is good the coach
is amazing they can move the ball and
put up yards i mean even when they were
going 3 and 13 and 6 and 10 early on in
shanahan's tenure they were exciting on
offense you know they just had you know
a cj beathard who was careless with the
football and they were young and they
were learning their way so uh there is
something to that it's a shame for jimmy
g because in that jets game where he got
hurt he was really playing well he
really was and was battling through the
injury at that time as he was playing
well so hopefully this doesn't set him
back a little bit um but you know the
way this schedule is [ __ ] shook out for
the 49ers it's just it's very favorable
i mean the eagles this week they're a
team that's kind of on the ropes we'll
see where jimmy g is for this
but and then i believe the week after
that's another easy game where you just
sit there and go
wow i want to say it's the dolphins or
somebody like that that that week right
there there it is it's the dolphins so
you know even if they lost this week
they're better than the dolphins they
could be sitting there going man we've
lost half of our damn team and like the
mash lineup here and we're still three
and two and just about to get healthy
because you're right that next stretch
whoa oh my gosh
oh my gosh rams patriots seahawks
packers saints rams bills
with that yeah get your wins while you
can 49ers and you can watch the 49ers
hosting the philadelphia eagles sunday
night football this week that precision
offense and i'm not going to count out
the 49ers because i believe in your guy
kyle i think he's a budding bill
belichick he's finding a way to
win hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports